اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير نستكمل واياكم
هذه التغطيه المتواصله للمنعرج الخطير
الذي دخل فيه السودان بعد القتال العنيف
بين وحدات الجيش بقياده الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان ووحدات الدعم السريع بقياده
الجنرال محمد حمدان دقلو فاليوم الثاني
على التوالي تتواصلوا الاشتباكات بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع خاصه
في محيط مقر القياده العمل للقوات المسلحه
في الخرطوم
وقد نفى الجيش سيطره الدعم السريع على برج
القوات البحريه قائلا انه تعرض لحريق
نتيجه الاشتباك وقد تمت السيطره على
النيران دون اصابات كما اكد الجيش السيطره
على قواعد الدعم السريع في بورتسودان
وكسلا والقضارف والدمازين وكوستي وجادوكلي
وكرري مؤكدنا ان قواته تدير المعركه بثبات
وتركيز عاليين خاصه بعد السيطره على اكبر
قاعده للدعم السريع في كرري بام درمان بكل
عنا صرها واسلحتها
وقد افادت مصادر في السودان ان الجيش
استطاع اطلاق سراح اللواء ركن الصادق سيد
الذي كان اسيرا في معسكر الدعم السريع
بكرره اللواء سيد كان قد انتدب للعمل في
الدعم السريع واعتقل بعد فض اعتصام
القياده العامه لاتهامه بالطلوع في هذه
الاحداث
اقول للسيد الغايب
سياده الصادق
الحمد لله على السلامه يا اخي ودارينك
الشعب السوداني
والحمد لله على السلامه
والحمد لله والشكر لله على كل حال نحمد
الله انه يعني
القانون وتمردوا على
قوات المسلحه
ومن البدايه كان كلامنا يعني الله اكبر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
الحمد لله
مسيطر عليها بوا
سطه وقبل ذلك اعلن قوات الدعم السريع
اسقطت طائره صباح اليوم وسبق واعلنت هذه
القوات اسقاط طائره مسيره في قاعده قرار
العسكريه اضافه للسيطره على برج القوات
البحريه بالقياده العامه
وبينما تتواصلوا للشبكات العنيفه بين
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع والتي تنذر
بمستوى غير مسبوق من التوتر ما قد يؤدي
الى حرب اهليه بحسب مراقبين دعونا اعزائي
المشاهدين نتابع في هذا العرض للمقارنه
بين القوتين ونتعرف اكثر على عدد العناصر
والاليات لدى كل منهما
الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع التاسيس
الجيش السوداني تاسس في عام
1925 قوات الدعم السريع تاسست في اغسطس
2013 التعداد العسكري الجيش السوداني يبلغ
نحو ربع مليون جندي قوات الدعم تقدر بنحو
مئه الف مقاتل الترسانه العسكريه الجويه
الجيش السوداني لديه 191 طائره حربيه
45 مقاتله 37 طائره هجوميه وخ وعشرون
طائره شحن عسكري قوات الدعم لا تمتلك اي
طائرات
الترسانه العسكريه البريه الجيش السوداني
يمتلك 20 منصه الصواريخ
170 دبابه
403 مدرعات سبعه الاف مركبه عسكريه قوات
الدعم لديها اسلحه خفيفه ومتوسطه 10 الاف
سياره رباعيه الدفع الجيش السوداني يحتل
المرتبه الخامسه والسبعين عالميا في قائمه
اقوى جيوش العالم
[موسيقى]
وهذا فيديو اعزائي المشاهدين فيديو متداول
لهروب عناصر قوات الدعم السريع بعد
الضربات الجويه التي طالت قاعدتهم
لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل اذهب الى لندن
الان ينضم الي من هناك الكاتب الصحفي خالد
الاعسر سيد خالد اهلا وسهلا بك هنالك
زوبعه من المواقف المتناقضه حول حدود
سيطره كل طرف على المواقع العسكريه
والاستراتيجيه تحديدا في العاصمه الخرطوم
اولا ما هي المعلومات المتوافر لديك
واي جديد يتصل بالمشهد الميداني في ظل هذا
التناقض في المواقف
يعني ينهي هذه المعركه بما يفيد السودان
والشعب السوداني والرحمه والمغفره للشهداء
وعين الشفاء للجرحى المعلومات المتوفره
حتى الان ان هذه المعركه اديرت بهنكا
عاليه جدا من قبل الجيش السوداني وهي
معركه وطنه ومعرفه مصير تحتاج الى
نوع من الوضوح والشفافيه في ان الذي وقع
هو جريمه كبرى ارتكبتها قياده الدعم
السريع بخروجه عن سلطه وقياده المؤسسه
العسكريه المؤسسه العسكريه السودانيه
ممثله في الجيش الوطني ظلت يعني تلوك
الصبر ويعني قبضت فتره طويله جدا تنظر
لغوات الدعم السريعه التي ارادت ان تجعل
من نفسها زراعه عسكري في
لعسكره المرحله الانتقاليه وتكون زراعه
لقوه مدنيه يائسه
كانت في السلطه مرتين وتريد ان تعود من
جديد اذا الحراك الذي يحدث الان هو فيه
خير كبير
ولكن لطموح محمد حمدان دغنون الذي دفعته
اليه بعض الاستشاريات الخاطئه من حوله من
بعض القوى السياسيه التي ارا تفرض نفوز
ماليش مسلحه
متفلته عن قيادتها العسكريه لكي تعود الى
السلطه خالد يعني كل طرف يلقي اللوم على
الطرف الاخر يعني بعد مرحله كان يقال فيها
انهم قلب واحد وسلاح واحد الان بدات
الاتهامات المتبادله بالامس سمعنا الجنرال
محمد حمدان دقله يتهم الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان بالغدر والكيد وسوى ذلك من
اتهامات
لنضع هذه هذا الامر جانبا يتحدث عن الامور
الميدانيه فقط الان لان الصوره التي تردنا
من تحديدا من الخرطوم يعني والتي نشاهدها
الان على الشاشه هذه الاعمده الهائله من
الدخان نتيجه القصر السؤال يعني اعيد
واساله اياك بطريقه اخرى مع تقدم الوقت هل
يمكن القول ان الجيش بدا يستعيد زمام
المبادره تحديدا في العاصمه الخرطوم ام لا
الامور تبقى سجالا وغير واضحه تماما
بالتراكم الطويل وامكانيات الجيش الرسمي
واضحا لمعادله المعادله الامنيه ستعود في
المحصله النهائيه للجيش الذي يحدث الان
حسب المعلومات المتوفره ان هناك جيوب من
بعض القوات الدعم السريعه التي تفرغت بحكم
انها تفقد الان التواصل مع غياداتها
والقوات السودانيه تتعامل مع هذه القوات
في مناطق مختلفه التي تشاهد من من دخان
تصاعد لعبه ضد الدخان وهذه الاصوات هي
تعامل من القوات الجويه السودانيه ومن
القيادات العسكريه في في المدرعات وفي في
اقسام مختلفه من الجيش للتعامل مع هذه
الحاله ولكن المعلومات التي تتوفر ان
منطقه ام درمان على سبيل المثال التي يشرف
عليها الفريق ياسر العطا هي شبه تشهد حاله
الاستقرار كذلك منطقه بحري الامور
الاوضاعتي الى حد كبير ظلت القضيه
الاساسيه الان هي السجال الذي يدور حول
قياده القوات المسلحه وما عرف بالغرفه
السيطره واداره العمليات التي يدير
البرهان والكباشي هؤلاء هم المعنيين بهذه
الجزئيه وبالتالي في تقديرها ان الذي
تشاهده الان هو مرحله متقدمه من فرض
النفوز الرسمي للجيشه الوطني صحيح ان هناك
تضحيات وضحايا وهذا عمري مرفوض ولكن الامر
الان في تقديره هو يسير في اتجاه سيطره
الجيش الوطني وفرض الامر الواقع وهذا يبدو
واضحا حتى من بيانات التي تصدر من الناطق
الرسمي للقوات المسلحه السودانيه استاذ
خالد تم التساؤلات يعني انه اذا كان قوات
الدعم السريع وعديدها يقدر بمئه الف وهي
قوات مدربه وشاركت في القتال في جنوب
السودان وفي مسميات يعني بتعرف كانت انه
قوات تجمان مجموعات الجنجاويد انضمت الى
وصار اسمها قوات دعم السريعه او جزء كبير
منها هنا السؤال هل يمكن هل يستطيع اي من
الطرفين الحسم ام لا هذه الحرب فتحت الان
لتبقى طويلا وطويلا
هو بكل تاكيد لا احد يرغب في ان تستمر
الحرب بالعكس انا في تقدير الشخصي
القيادات العسكريه التي تتبع لقوات الدعم
السريع ومحمد والقائد محمد حمدان هي
قيادات خرجت من صلب المؤسسه العسكريه وهي
تدرك بحجم حجم المسؤوليه الوطنيه وهذا ما
بدا واضحا جدا في سيطره الجيش على العديد
من القواعد والمراكز التي كانت تقيم فيها
القوات الدعم السريع بدا من الدمازين
والقضارف وكسنه وتورسودان وكادوبلي وحتى
في غرض السودان اذا المؤسسه يعني هذه حاله
نادره ان الجيش الذي
تتكون من قوات الدعم السريع هو اصلا يتبع
لقوات حرس الحدود التي كان تابعه للجيش
السوداني عندما كان الزعيم مسيرال يقود
هذه القوات السابقه ومن ثم تطور الحال الى
ان وصلت في عام 2013 في قوات الدعم السريع
وبعدها تم
في 2017 واتبعني الجيش القومي في قياده
القوات المسلحه انا في تقديم ان هذه
المعرفه هي معركه وقت قصير جدا وفي الاخر
الى طبيعته ونحن لا ندعو للحروب ولا نشجع
طرف دون اخر هذه القوات كانها دور وطني
محوري في الدفاع على السودان كما تفضلت عن
في حروف الجنوب في دارفور ولكن لا يمكن ان
يوصل بها الجنون لدرجه ان تسيطر على قواعد
عسكريه في مدن امنه كما هو حال مدى المروي
هذه المدن لم تشهد هذه النوع من الصراع
هذه هذه النوع من ادخال وضع عسكريه مدجه
بالاسلحه الصغيره وسط المدنيين كما يحدث
الان في الخرطوم والقياده العامه هذا لم
يحدث في تاريخ الحياه السياسيه والعسكريه
اذا هذه القوات يجب كان يجب ان تفكر 1000
مره قبل ان تغضب على هذه العمليه لم تضع
ادنى حد احترام
هذا الدم السوداني عندما سجد
بزراعه عسكريه ومغلف بشكل عسكري الغايه
الاساسيه كانت هي بعض القوى السياسيه
الصغيره ارادت ان تزيد بهذه القوات في
معركه غير متكافئه مع الجيش الوطني وذكرتم
انتم في تقريركم الان اما الجيش يمتلك
قدرات مهوله قياسا بقوات الدعم السريع
التي هي
وليست الجيش القومي الوطني السوداني طيب
قلت ان الجيش يمتلك مؤهلات وعتاد مهول
ساسالك عن يعني لماذا حتى الساعه لم يعني
لم يستخدم الجيش بقياده الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان كل هذه العتاج يعني شاهدنا
استخدام سلاح الجو بعض من سلاح المدرعات
ولكن ساسالك بعد قليل عن الاسلحه الثقيله
الاخرى
استاذ خالد هل معركه الخرطوم ستكون ام
المعارك بالنسبه للطرفين بمعنى ان من
يسيطر على الخرطوم
ستكون له مالات الامور ام لا تمت ولايات
ومدن اخرى لا تقل اهميه
بكل تاكي
المتعارض عليه في علوم العسكريه ان مجرد
السيطره على القياده
يعني اثري بعض القيادات العسكريه التي
تصدر التعليمات العسكريه وهنا لابد ان
نعود لفكره ان التفلت الذي بدر من بعض
غاده الدعم السريع هو حرير بنا ان نتناول
هذه الجزئيه اذا يعني قياده الدعم السريع
هي التي
اصدرت وضاربه بعرض الحائط كل التعليمات
والقواعد العسكريه المتعارضه عليها لكن
فيما يلي تريز الجيش وتعامله مع هذه
الحالات حسب ما بدر وحسب تواصلي مع بعض
القيادات العسكريه وتابع هذا الشعب هم لا
يريدون ان يستخدموا ان ارادوا ان يستخدموا
كل القوه العسكريه بالحجم الكبير هذه
المعركه فيها
اربع
انقضاء اهدافهم والتعامل بحساسيه مفرطه
يعني في صياغه في سياق حفظ الدم السوداني
وعدم اهدار ارواح المدنيين وبالتالي هذا
يقول ذكرته منذ قليل لماذا ذكر الله الدعم
العسكري
وزني الى اجابه وهذا في الموابل تقابل
قابل الجيش بتعامل الرفيع بانتقائيه
بتحديد اهداف محدده استخدام محسوب بدقه
للقوات والقدرات العسكريه وهذا ايضا يحمد
للمؤسسه العسكريه الرسميه باعتبار مؤسسه
الدوله رصيره وجيش متمرس يعني بالمئه عام
وبالتالي هذا يشمل الاجابات المطلوبه
بالنسبه لكل من لندن الكاتب الصحفي خالد
الاعسر شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
امبراطوريتان عسكريتان قامتا على انقاض
حكم البشير رجلان حكم العسكري في السودان
نفايا مرارا وجود اي خلاف بينهما وحجم
التراشق الكلامي في خانه حرب زائفه ابتدعت
اعلاميا بهدف خرق الصف الواحد الا انه ما
نزلق للمواجهه المسلحه
رئيس مجلس السياده الانتقالي في السودان
عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد القوات البريه في
عهد البشير صار قائدا للجيش النظامي فيما
اسست ثاني اي محمد حمدان دقلو المعروف
بحمدتي قوات الدعم السريع معتمدا عالمي
للشاه خاضت حربا داميه في دارفور لكنه لم
يعد يرضى بلقب الرجل الثاني في الدوله او
النائب
تهديد فعلي شكله احمدتي للبرهان معززا
امبراطوريته بجيش خاص قوامه مئه الف عنصر
اي ما يوازي تقريبا حجم قوات الجيش
السوداني فضلا عن تكسب اقتصادي نتج عن عقد
صفقات مع شركات دوليه
في الاتفاق الايطالي اداه للمحافظه على
مكتسباته لكن التوقيع فشل مرتين بسبب
خلافات حول دمج قوه الدعم السريع في الجيش
ومداه الزمني ووضعيه قياده القوات ففي حين
اراد البرهان اتمام الدمج وفقا لقواعد
الجيش وانظمته تمسك احمدتي باعاده هيكله
قياده الجيش العليا اولا حتى يكون جزءا
منها قبل دمج قواته وتقليص نفوذه
بالكذب ما بنلتقي قدام احسن نمشي
قضايا خلافيه اخرى شقت طريقها الى
المنظومه الامنيه مثل اصلاح الجيش وابعاد
انصار النظام السابق عنه كما مثلت اداره
الملفات الخارجيه ونسج نائب البرهان
لعلاقات عابره للحدود تحديا كبيرا
للجانبين فحمل التي متهم من قبل الجيش
بخلق علاقات دبلوماسيه موازيه للدوله
وهذا اعزائي المشاهدين مقطع فيديو متداول
يظهروا حجم الاشتباكات في محيط سجن كوبر
في خرطوم بحري اذا هذا فيديو متداول الان
عن هذه الاشتباكات في محيط هذا السجن
بالطبع اعمده الدخان تتصاعد كما نشاهد في
هذا الفيديو
الى نزار مقداوي الان هو معي من مروى نزار
اهلا
وسهلا بك جديد المشهد الميداني من عندك
خصوصا في محيط قاعده مروي المعلومات
متضاربه الجيش يقول انه
هذه القاعده محاصره تماما وفي كلام على
انه السيطره ما زالت لقوات الدعم السريع
في هذه القاعده اخر المعلومات المتوفر
لديك
اخر المعلومات عبر شهود عيان نحن ننتقل من
منطقه الى منطقه بحكم الوضعيه الامنيه
شهود عيان اكدوا قبل قليل من مروي
بتجدد ارتفاع اعمده الدخان من داخل قاعده
مروي الجويه العسكريه نحن الان بصدد
التاكد عبر الصوره لمعرفه ما الذي يدور
بالتاكيد داخل هذه القاعده هل تجددت عمليه
الاشتباك هل حاولت قوات الدعم السريعه
الخروج من تمركزها داخل القاعده ومن ثم
تعاملت معها القوات السودانيه او قوات
الجيش التي تحاصر هذه القاعده حتى اللحظه
نحاول ان نجيب على هذه التساؤلات بعد قليل
لمعرفه كافه التفاصيل حول اسباب التمدد
اعمده الدخان من امام او من داخل هذه
القاعده
نزار طيب ايضا في في الموضوع الانساني طب
عدد الضحايا من قتلى من جرحى هل
المستشفيات المحيطه مؤهله لا ستقبال هذه
الاعداد موضوع الكهرباء الماء الانترنت لو
تعطينا وتعطي المشاهدين فكره عن كل هذه
الامور لانه هذه كمان امور حياتيه مهمه
للناس المتواجدين في السودان
بالتاكيد الواقع الخدمي ومعاش الناس وواقع
المجتمعي هنا يعني بعد هذه التداعيات
للعمليه العسكريه التي بدات امس الخدمات
الان متوفره سواء كانت خدمه المياه خدمات
الاتصالات الهاتفيه لم تنقطع هنا في شمال
السودان
الطرق الرئيسه البريه لم تقطع خاصه الطريق
القاري الذي يربط بين السودان وبين
جمهوريه مصر العربيه يمر
عبر مئات الكيلومترات هنا في الولايه
الشماليه وصولا الى الحدود مع مصر خدمات
المياه متوفره كانت الكهرباء قد قطعت يوم
الامس من مدينه مروي ولكنها عادت الى بعض
الاحياء السكنيه المحاله التجاريه مغلقه
لكن تتوفر فيها المواد الغذائيه
المستشفيات الان تعمل خاصه المستشفى
العسكري القومي وهو يتبع للقوات المسلحه
السودانيه يوم الامس استقبل نحو 20 الى 30
من جرحى العمليه العسكريه التابعين للجيش
السوداني الى جانب ايضا مستشفى كريمه هي
احدى مدن هذه الولايه مدينه قريبه من
مدينه مروي ايضا استقبلت عدد من جرحى
ومصابي القوات المسلحه عدد المصابين داخل
المدنيين نحو خمسه اصابات تعرضوا لصبايا
خرجت من العمليه العسكريه بحكم ايضا وجود
هذه المجموعات المدنيه بالقرب من القاعده
العسكريه لكن الان الاوضاع مستقره السوق
الرئيس في هذه المدينه اغلق صباح الامس
بفعل
تداعيات الامنيه
هنالك عطله رسميه ستمتد الى ما بعد عيد
الاضحى او عيد الفطر المبارك للمدارس
مدارس الاساس الابتدائيه والمدارس
المتوسطه هنا في الولايه الشماليه الطرقات
السالكه الجسر الذي يربط بين مدينه مروي
ومدينه كريمه هو جسر حيوي الحركه فيه
مستمره المواطنون الان في منازلهم لا
يريدون ان يخرجوا خوفا ايضا من تبعات هذه
العمليه الوضع الصحي الان مطمئن هنالك
اطقم علاجيه موجوده في المستشفيات الهلال
الاحمر الان يباشر اعماله مع العلم بان
عدد من الاطباء اخرج بعد المناشدات بضروره
ان يكون الشباب على الاقل على مقربه من
المرافق الصحيه لتقديم خدمه الدم اذا ما
ادعت الحاجه لتوفير كميات من الدم لاسعاف
المرضى او المصابين نزار ابقى معي ساعود
اليك بعد قليل دعني اشرك من القاهره
الدكتور محمد فايز فرحات وهو مدير مركز
الاهرام للدراسات الدكتور محمد اهلا وسهلا
بك بدايه كيف تراقب القاهره ما يجري هل
فاجاتها سرعه الاحداث الدراماتي كيه بهذا
الشكل
والى اي مدى
يعني يمكن لتطور الاحداث بهذا الشكل ان
يهدد الامن القومي المصري يعني كون
السودان كما نعرف يعتبر حديقه خلفيه للامن
القومي المصري تفضل استاذ محمد
نعم يعني اعتقد ما حدث بالامس واليوم هو
محصله لتراكم مجموعه من الاشكالات القائمه
داخل المشهد السياسي والامني السوداني كما
نعلم منذ عام 2019 وحتى الان كانت هناك
محاولات لاداره مراحل الانتقاليه بدات
بالوثيقه الدستوريه ثم بعد في عام 2019 ثم
بعد ذلك الاتفاق جوبا للسلام ثم الاتفاق
الاطاري الذي وقع في ديسمبر الماضي لكن كل
هذه الوثائق كانت تواجه مشكلات كبيره اما
انه عكست يعني او واجهت اشكالات كبيره
بسبب الانقسام بين مكون عسكري والمكون
المدني او انقسامات بين المكون داخل
المكون المدني نفسه او يعني عدم انضمام
الاغلبيه الكافيه
من القوى السياسيه لهذه الوثائق زلت هناك
فصائل وقوه سودانيه خارج هذه الوثائق
جميعها وبالتالي كانت هناك اشكاليه تتعلق
بشرعيه المرحله الانتقاليه منذ ان بدات في
عام 2019 حتى الان بالاضافه الى ذلك يعني
ثم جاء التطور الاقصر الاكثر خطوره وهو
الانقسام بين مكون داخل المكون العسكري
بين الجيش النظامي الوطني السوداني وبين
قوات الدعم السريع وهذه كانت ظاهره يعني
استثنائيه القاعده الاساسيه في تاريخ
الدول والمجتمعات هو ان تكون هناك سلطه
واحده لديها القوه
والحق الشرعي في استخدام القوه وممارسه حق
الدفاع لكن يعني مثل هذه الظواهر دائما ما
تنتهي به مشكلات كبيره لانها تؤجل مشاكل
قائمه منذ البدايه حاله قوات الدعم السريع
كانت قائمه يعني هي مشكله كبيره كانت
قائمه في السودان منذ ان
نظام البشير ربما قبل ذلك كان هناك اطار
يحتوي هذه
الظاهره او يحتوي هذه القوه النظام
السياسي في السودان لكن بعد انهيار نظام
البشير انكشف الوضع الاستثنائي لهذه القوه
وبالتالي ما يحدث الان هو محصله
لتراكم كل هذه العوامل منذ عام 2019 وحتى
الان طيب اعود الى سؤالي شكرا على هذه
الاطلاله بس دكتور محمد كيف تراقب القاهره
ما يجري هل فاجاتها سرعه هذه الاحداث
الدراماتيكيه والسؤال الاستطراضي متى وتحت
اي ظرف يمكن للقاهره ان تتدخل
يعني فيما يتعلق بالشق الاول او السؤال
الاول هل تفاجات القاهره في القاهره كان
لديها موقف ثابت منذ بدء الازمه السودانيه
وهو ان الملف يخص السودانيين ويخص النخبه
السياسيه السودانيه لكن هناك وجهه نظر
مصريه هو اولا لابد ان تكون اي مرحله
انتقاليه لابد ان تقوم على توافق النخب
السياسيه لكن ان تظل مجموعه من النخب
السياسيه خارج هذه الاطر هذا ينعكس على
مدى شرعيه هذه الوثائق او الاطر وينعكس
دائما على مدى نجاحه المرحله الانتقاليه
فبالتالي استناده الى
تراكم هذه العوامل واستنادا الى يعني رؤيه
القاهره فيما يتعلق بالملف السوداني اعتقد
ان ما حدث بالامس ربما كان
متوقعا او على الاقل كان متوقعا لاغلب
الباحثين او المعنيين بالملف السوداني
ربما فقط يعني ما حدث ظهر الى سطح بشكل
مفاجئ لم يكن احد يتوقع ظهور هذا التحول
بهذه او هذا هذا هذه الاحداث بهذه
الدراماتيكيه كان البعض يدرك ان هناك
مشكله داخل المكون العسكري ظهرت بشكل واضح
بدءا من بدء الحديث عن دمج قوات الدعم
السريع في الجيش النظامي صحيح يعني هذا
هدف مهم وهو هدف في مصلحه الدوله
السودانيه في النهايه وفي مصلحه الامن
السوداني لكن طبيعي ان ظاهره مثل الدعم
السريع قوات الدعم السريع تكونت لديها
مصالح داخل النظام او داخل السودان
هذه المصالح بالتاكيد تدفعها او تشكل محدد
مهمل لديها في التحرك السياسي او في
التحرك الامني متى تدخل تتدخل القاهره في
الحقيقه القاهره لديها وجهه نظر فيما
يتعلق بكل المشكلات القائمه في الاقليم
وهو ان القوى السياسيه الداخليه او
الاطراف الداخليه هي المسؤول الرئيسي عن
اداره خلافاتها والمسؤول الرئيسي عن تحديد
مسارها في التطور السياسي والتطور
الاقتصادي
والاجتماعي لكن عندما يتاثر الامن القومي
المصري بالتاكيد مصر تتحرك لكن في الاطر
المعروفه وكان هذا هذه التحركات الواضحه
منذ الامس عندما دعت القاهره بالتعاون مع
المملكه العربيه السعوديه لاجتماع طارق
داخل جامعه الدول العربيه على مستوى
المندوبين وبالتاكيد لن تكون هذه هي
الاليه الاخيره هناك قمه مقبله لجامعه
الدول العربيه بالتاكيد هذا الملف سوف
يحظى بها الاهتمام الاكبر داخل يعني اجنده
القمه العربيه المقبله دكتور محمد رفقه مع
عيسى اسالك بعد قليل عن تاثير ما يجري من
احداث داميه في السودان على موضوع سد
النهضه وهو بتعرف موضوع حيوي جدا بالنسبه
الى القاهره ولكن ساعود اليك بعد قليل
اعزائي المشاهدين بعد الانتفاضه الشعبيه
التي اطاحت في ابريل من عام 2019
بحكم عمر حسن البشير بدا السودان مسيره
التحول لكن عراقيل مختلفه وقفت في الطريق
في ظل الصراع المحتدم على على السلطه في
هذا البلد
السودان رحله بحث طويله وشاقه عن الحريه
والديمقراطيه في هذا التقرير
السودان رحله شاقه من البحث عن الحريه
والديمقراطيه حكايه طويله لم تكتب لها
نهايه سعيده حتى الان
الان كم من ذلك ان هذا البلد العربي
والافريقيه انزلق نحو القتال بدل لغه
السلام والحوار
التحول نحو الحكم المستقر مثل شعله امل
حين تمت الاطاحه بنظام البشير عقب انتفاضه
شعبيه في ربيع العام 2019 في اغسطس من
السنه ذاتها وافق الجيش على تقاسم السلطه
مع المدنيين ريثما يتم اجراء انتخابات لكن
الترتيب تعطل وسرعان من قلب على ما التزم
به الزي العسكري في السودان وكحال اغلب
بلدان الجنوب يشكل قوه مهيمنه منذ
استقلاله عام
1956 اذ خاض حروبا داخليه وقام بانقلابات
متكرره ولديه حيازات اقتصاديه ضخمه حظي
الجيش بدعم داخلي من فصائل متمرده استفادت
من اتفاق السلام في 2020 ومن المخضرمين في
حكومه البشير الذين عادوا الى الخدمه
المدنيه الصراع بين قائد الجيش عبد الفتاح
البرهان ابنائبه محمد حمدان دقلو يوازيه
صراع اخر مع المدنيين الذين يضغطون من اجل
الرقابه على الجيش ودمج قوات الدعم السريع
شبه العسكريه التي لها وضع قوي في الجيش
النظامي امر اخر يدخل في المعادله السودان
موجود في منطقه مضطربه يحدها البحر الاحمر
ومنطقه الساحل والقرن الافريقي استقطب
موقعه الاستراتيجي وثرواته الزراعيه قوى
مختلفه ما ادى الى تعقيد فرص نجاح
الانتقال وها هو الان في طريق حرب اهليه
ستعيده سنوات الى الوراء بلال الوجداني
العربيه
ونستقبل هذه التغطيه للاحداث الداميه في
السودان دكتور محمد فايز فرحات اهلا وسهلا
بكم مجددا ولكن قبل ان اعود اليك دعني
اشرك مراسل العربيه في الخرطوم سالم
الهاشمي انضم الينا الان سالم اهلا وسهلا
بك جديد المشهد الميداني من عندك تحديدا
في ظل هذا يعني التناقض في الروايات لكل
طرف حول حدود السيطره على المراكز
الاستراتيجيه في العاصمه الخرطوم وهل من
معلومات عن معركه مقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم يعني حتى
الساعه المعلومات متضاربه ايضا حول ما
يجري في محيط المقر
نعم ايضا هناك باب متضاربه حول ما يدور في
داخل القياده العامه للجيش السوداني لكن
الجيش السوداني قبل قليل نشر الفيديو
لانتشار جلودها القوات الذريه في القياده
العامه في القياده العامه للجيش السوداني
كان احتدام القتال في هذه اللحظات
الاشتباكات ايضا التي تدور ليست في
القياده العامه وحدها ايضا هناك اشتباكات
في منطقه بحيث محيط كوبر وكافوري مع طلعات
للطيران جاءت متفاوته وان قلت عن يوم امس
بشكل واضح في هذا اليوم ايضا نشهد
اشتباكات هنا في قلب العاصمه الخرطوم في
القياده العامه للجيش وفي امتدادات اخرى
جنوب القياده العامه للجيش السوداني
وغربي وجنوب مطار الخرطوم كذلك المناطق
التي هي في الصحافه والدين وهذه المناطق
فيها العديد من الاشتباكات تسمع فيها ذوي
اطلاق نار وفي هذه اللحظات نستمع الى ذوي
لاطلاق النار وكذلك صوت المدفعيات الثقيله
كذلك في محيط القياده العامه وكذلك في
بقيه انحاء الخرطوم الشوارع الخرطوم ما
زالت حذره قلقات توتر شوف كل المواطنين
خاصه مع انقطاع التيار الكهربائي انقطاع
كذلك الامداد المائي عن معظم البيوت في
البيوت السودانيه كذلك اغلاق كل الاسواق
والمحل التجاريه ما يجعل المواطنين في
حيره من امرهم في استعداداتهم لافطار
اليوم وهم في شهر رمضان وحتى استعدادات
العيد كذلك كل هذه التفاصيل تغيبه لان
المواطن هو قلق ومتوتر وحذر كذلك لان
الشوارع تبدو شبه خاليه الان بس طب سالم
هل يمكن اعطاء خارطه لحدود سيطره كل طرف
في العاصمه الخرطوم ام لا حتى الساعه
الامور غير واضحه وما هي نوعيه الاسلحه
المستخدمه اليوم يعني في الاشتباكات او
المواجهات لانه عم نشوف كل يوم عم تزداد
يعني يزج كل طرف بنوعيه من الاسلحه يعني
شاهدنا سلاح الطيران المدفعيه الثقيله
نوعيه الاسلحه المستخدمه اليوم اذا كان
لديك معلومات ايضا
بكل تاكيد كلامك في الجزئيه الاخيره
بالذات صحيح تماما لانه اليوم الانفجارات
وذوي هذه الاسلحه
حقيقه مخيف ويهز حتى البيوت في المناطق
القريبه من مقر القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني وليست القريبه منه فحسب حتى
مناطق في بحري تستمع الى ذوي هذه
الانفجارات وكانها في ذات المنزل وهي في
القياده العامه تبعد حوالي اكثر من يستطيع
ان نقول 15 الى 20 كم من القياده العامه
للجيش السوداني هذا الامر بالفعل الذي
يدعو الى القلق والى التوتر كذلك بالنسبه
لسؤالك عن يعني الخريطه او امتداد كل طرف
عن الاخر لا توجد يعني خريطه واضحه حقيقه
لاولا حذر المواطنين من الحركه حذر
كلا الطرفين كذلك لكن في طريقنا الى هنا
على الاقل عرفنا بعض المناطق التي تتمركز
فيها قوات من الدعم السريع شرقيه مطار
الخرطوم شارع عبيد الختم وجنوب مطار
الخرطوم لفت الجريف وغرب مطار الخرطوم
وكذلك في شارع المطار اما امتداد الجيش
السوداني في محيط القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني كذلك هنا قوات من الجيش السوداني
بالنسبه للجسور جسر المقدمه وجسر كذلك جسر
القوات المسلحه المطل على النيل الازرق
وهو الجسر الخرطوم وكذلك جسر كوبرا هذه
تتمركز هي قوات من الجيش في ذات الاثناء
في هذه اللحظات اشتباكات في جسر كوبر من
جهه بحري في منطقه منطقه عسكريه اصلا فيها
سكنات للجيش السوداني وفيها سكنات كذلك
للدعم السريع وفيها سكنات لجهاز الامن
المخابرات العامه في هذه المنطقه الان
تجري ايضا معركه في تلك المنطقه بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني طيب سالم
ارجوك ان تبقى معي ساشرك الدكتور
محمد فايز فرحات بعد قليل وسنظهر الان في
هذا المقطع في هذا المقطع الفيديو
مقطع الفيديو لنشر
جنود الجيش السوداني
في امام
برج القياده البريه في القياده العامه كما
يقال لي نشاهد الفيديو مجددا
اذا الجيش السوداني ينشر صور الانتشار
جنوده امام برج المراقبه في مقر القياده
العامه في هذا الفيديو اذا الجيش السوداني
ينشر صورا لانتشار جنوده امام برج
المراقبه في مقر القياده العامه كما نشاهد
في هذا الفيديو بالطبع كانت المعارك
محتدمه تماما
امام مقر القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
سالم ساعود اليك دعني اشرك مجددا الدكتور
محمد فايز فرحات من القاهره دكتور محمد
كنت قد سالتك قبل ان ننتقل الى سالم
الهاشمي تاثير ما يجري من احداث داميه في
السودان على موضوع سد النهضه وهو موضوع
حيوي جدا جدا جدا بالنسبه للقاهره
نعم يعني مصر والسودان في جبهه واحده
لانهم دولتي مصابه بالتاكيد
وبالتالي المعطيات الخاصه بوضع مصر
والسودان كدولتين مصب يلعب دور مشترك في
تحديد او توسيع القواسم المشتركه بين
البلدين فيما يتعلق باداره هذه المشكله او
هذه الازمه فيما يتعلق بتاثير ما يحدث
الان في السودان على هذه القضيه بالتاكيد
على المدى القصير الدوله السودانيه سوف
تكون مشغوله في هذه الاحداث لكن السؤال
على المدى الابعد في رايي ان هناك
سيناريوهين بالتاكيد السيناريو الاول هو
اذا ما استمرت هذه الازمه ودخلت السودان
في حرب اهليه وهذا سيناريو لا نتمناه ولا
يتمناه اي يعني اي دوله جار او اي دوله
عربيه للسودان لكن اذا هناك سيناريو اخر
وهو ان تخرج الدوله السودانيه دوله قويه
عندما تحسم احد الظواهر الموجوده او احد
الاشكالات الرئيسيه في السودان في راي هذا
قد يعطي شرعيه اكبر للدوله السودانيه
باعتبار وللجيش النظام السوداني باعتباره
هو القوه الوحيده التي تمتلك الحق الشرعي
في استخدام القوه العسكريه هذه مساله
بالتاكيد اذا حسمها حسمتها القوه
السودانيه او الاطراف السودانيه هذا
سينعكس بالتاكيد على قوه الدوله السودانيه
وهذا سنعكس بالتاكيد ايضا على قدره
السودان على اداره كل المشكلات الخارجيه
لكن في رايي هناك متغير مهم يجب اخذه في
الاعتبار عندما يعني نحاول الاجابه على
هذا السؤال هل المشكله الحقيقيه فيما
يتعلق بمشكله سد سد الاثيوبي تتعلق
بالسودان او تتعلق بمصر في الحقيقه هي
تتعلق باثيوبيا بالمنهج الاثيوبي في
التعامل مع هذه القضيه يعني لو افترضنا ان
هناك مفاوضات جاده الان من الجانب
الاثيوبي مع دولتي المصب اعتقد ان وجود
الفرق المس الفنيه والدبلوماسيه المسؤوله
عن اداره هذه المشكله سواء في مصر او
السودان هي فرق يعني تعرف طبيعه مهمتها
يمكن ان تدير هذه المفاوضات بمعزل عن
الاوضاع انا مرضت سؤالي عمرو برايي يعتبر
على متغير مهم هو الموقف الاثيوبي طيب
دكتور محمد يعني انا يعني انا في خلفيه
السؤال سؤال اخر هل ما يجري في السودان هو
شان داخلي سوداني
وخلاف داخلي بحث على السلطه بين هذين
الطرفين ام لا ما يجري هو انعكاس لقوه
النفوذ الاقليميه والدوليه في المشهد
السوداني
يعني اذا مسؤوليه القوه الداخليه
السودانيه بالتاكيد هذه المسؤوليه لا يمكن
تجاهلها من جانب اي حلل او جاي جانب اي
متابع للملف السوداني او القضيه السودانيه
هذه الظاهره موجوده قبل عام 2019 ولكنها
فرضت نفسها او فرضت انعكاساتها
وارتداداتها على المشهد السوداني بعد عام
2019 من خلال الحالات الازدواجيه القائمه
فيما يتعلق بالمتغير الخارجي بالتاكيد لا
يمكن ايضا اغفال هذا المتغير لكن في رايي
ان المشكله الاساسيه في فيما يتعلق بالملف
السوداني هو تعدد الاطر الدوليه المسؤوله
عن الملف السوداني او التي تحاول اداره
الملف السوداني كما نعلم هناك
ادوار مباشره لقوه دوليه مثل الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وقوه دوليه اخرى تدير
هذه المسائل بشكل احادي الجانب في العلاقه
مع السودان هناك ايضا الاليه الثلاثيه
المعروفه او التي تضم الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه الايجاد هناك ده
ادوار المبعوثين الدولي وبالتالي كل هؤلاء
الفاعلين بالتاكيد ينسبون علاقات مباشره
مع اطراف داخليين
وهذا ينعكس على مواقف الاطراف الداخليه
ومدى قدراتها او استعدادها على الدخول في
عمليات سياسيه حقيقيه تنتهي بالخروج من
المراحل الانتقاليه الطويله ففي ان تعدد
الفاعلين الدوليين يعني كان مشكله في
السودان وبالتالي حتى لاحظنا في بعض
المراحل كان هناك انتقادات من جانب
البرهان
لاداء الاليه الثلاثيه نفسها كان هناك
مشكلات قائمه بين الجانبين تعدد وجهات
النظر وتعدد الفاعلين في رايي كان احد
العوامل التي ساهمت في تعميق المشكله او
على الاقل يعني اعطاء اوزان نسبيه مختلفه
للفاعلين داخل السودان تالي هذا
ساسالك يعني ساسالك بعد قليل نعم سياسيه
مستقره ساسالك بعد قليل اذا كان الوقت
يسمح بطرح اي مبادره على الاقل مبادره
توقف اطلاق النار في هذه المرحله ام لا
سبق السيف العزل كما يقال ولكن دعني يعني
في اطلاله على المشهد الطبي في السودان
فقد ناشدت نقابه اطباء السودان المنظمات
الانسانيه والهيئات الصحيه الدوليه
والاقليميه لتوفير الامداد الطبي لجميع
المستشفيات والمرافق الصحيه بالخرطوم
ومناطق الاشتباكات بالولايات المختلفه
وتامين ممرات امنه للمدنيين والسماح
بالمرور الامن لعربات الاسعاف والكوادر
الطبيه
وحثت ايضا المجتمع الدولي والمنظمات
الحقوقيه والدبلوماسيه على الضغط لالزام
الطرفي الصراع المسلح بوقف القتال
[موسيقى]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
استلام
معسكر كرري للدعم السريع
عرباتهم ومدرعاتهم
[موسيقى]
بطبع اعزائي المشاهدين هذا فيديو نشرته
قوات الدعم السريع تقول فيه انها احكمت
السيطره على القصر الجمهوري بالطبع لم
يتثنى لنا التاكد من صحه هذا
الفيديو اذا قوات الدعم السريع تقول انها
احكمت السيطره على القصر الجمهوري في هذا
الفيديو الذي نشرته قبل بعض الوقت بالطبعا
لم نتمكن من التاكد من صحته من مصادر
مستقله خصوصا في هذه
المرحله نتيجه هذه الاحداث الداميه
وادرماتيكيه المتسارعه التي يشهدها
السودان اعود الى مراسلنا في الخرطوم سالم
الهاشمي سالم كنا تحدثنا عن الوضع الطبي
مع نزار البغداوي منذ قليل من مروي
بالنسبه الى الوضع الطبي والاستشفائي في
الخرطوم هل من متابعه لما يجري الاطقم
الطبيه والصحيه مجهزه عدد القتلى عدد
الجرحى كل ذلك
نعم بالنسبه للوضع طبي حتى هذه اللحظه
التي اطباء السودان المركزيه منذ
التوجه الى الاماكن التي فيها الجرحى
المصابين
هم نسبه للشكاوى التي تكررت من ان بعض
المستشفيات عليها ضغط عالي جدا بالنسبه
للاصابات خاصه بعض المقام الكبيره التي
اصدر السودان المركزيه في اخر احصائيه لها
بالنسبه للمصابين والجرحى والقتله كذلك
الذين تم استهدافهم من المدنيين في هذه
الحرب ايضا هنا نؤكد ايضا ان بعض
المستشفيات عليها ضغط عالي يعني جاءتها
حالات عديده جدا
وما زالت تستقبل هذه الحالات
لعلاجها في بحري وفي الخرطوم وفي ام درمان
مستشفى ام درمان التعليمي مستشفى الدولي
في بحري وكذلك المستشفى الجوده هنا في
الخرطوم ومستشفيات اخرى كذلك في انحاء
العاصمه الخرطوم هذا بالمجمل ربما هو
الوضع الصحي لكن الوضع الانساني ما زالت
ارشادات على على الذين يعني علقوا في
المناطق التي تشهد الاشتباكات العنيفه
هناك مناشدات عاليه جدا بان يحكم الطرفين
صوت العقل على الاقل وقت اطلاق النار
هؤلاء العالم من الابطال والتلاميذ الذين
لا ذنبلهم في هذه الحرب وليسوا شريكين
فيها بالطبعوا بكل تاكيد يعني
فهذه المناشدات لم تجد اذن صاغيه من اطراف
النزاع
وما زال الوضع كما هو حتى الان طيب سالم
يبقى معي ساعود اليك بعد قليل اعود الى
الدكتور محمد فايز فرحات من القاهره دكتور
محمد كنت قد سالته هل الوقت يسمح لطرح اي
مبادره للحل على الاقل وقف اطلاق النار
بين الطرفين ام لا يعني لا كلمه تعلو فوق
صوت المدفع الان
يعني في رايي يعني ما زالت هناك فرصه لكن
سؤال ممن ستاتي هذه المبادره واعتقد ربما
تاتي من جامعه الدول العربيه لكن الاهم ان
يتبع هذه المبادره محاوله يعني والاقناع
الاطراف لي بالجلوس على مائده المفاوضات
لهذا تحقيق هدف رئيسي وهو ان يكون هناك
قوه عسكريه نظاميه واحده داخل الدوله
السودانيه واعتقد هذا هو الهدف الذي كان
يتم النقاش حوله بين الجيش السوداني وبين
قوات الدعم السريع لكن حدث خلاف في
اللحظات الاخيره او على الاقل ان قوات
الدعم السريعه ربما رات ان من ليس من
مصلحتها الاندماج في الجيش السوداني او ان
شروط الاندماج لم تكن تتوافق مع رؤيتها
فبالتالي السؤال هو
الخطوه الاولى هو اقناع الاطراف
بوقف اطلاق النار اولا ثم الجلوس على
مائده المفاوضات للوصول الى الهدف الذي
كان موضوع النقاش بين الجانبين وفقا
للمرحله الانتقاليه او وفقا للوثائق
الاخيره التي تجري في السودان هو كيف يمكن
اقناع الاطراف بالوصول الى الهدف المشترك
الذي يتناسب في الحقيقه مع يعني طبيعه
الدول في العالم الدول في العالم هناك
ظاهره متوافق عليها وان تكون هناك قوه
نظاميه واحده تمتلك الحق الشرعي في
استخدام القوه والدفاع عن الدوله وحمايه
امنها الوطني وسلامه اراضيها هذا هو الهدف
في رايي اذا يعني تم جمع الاطراف كيف يمكن
الوصول الى هذا الهدف سيكون هذا مفيد جدا
للدوله السودانيه وللمجتمع السوداني
وسيجنب الدوله والمجتمع يعني هذا ما يجري
الان في الشارع السوداني دكتور محمد هل
بقي اي شيء من الاتفاق الايطالي برايك ام
لا هذا الاتفاق لفظ انفاسه الاخيره وبشكل
نهائي مع اطلاق اول طلقه في هذه المواجهات
يعني اعتقد هذا سؤال مهم بالفعل وسيجيب
عنه الاحداث التي ستجري في الفتره المقبله
يعني
بالتاكيد اذا حسمت مساله موقف قوات الدعم
السريع هذا يعني سيكشف عن موازين قوه
جديده داخل السودان ربما تساعد بشكل كبير
على توقيع الاتفاق الاطاري بشكل نهائي
ودمج القوى السياسيه دمج مزيد من القوى
السياسيه في هذا الاتفاق لانه كما يعني
قلت قبل ذلك ما سيحدث او اذا تم يعني حسم
الاشكال الكبير الان في السودان هذا
سينعكس على موازين القوى في السودان وربما
يكون في مصلحه الاتفاق الايطالي بس كده
الطرفين لديهما من القوه دكتور محمد
والعتاد والدعم حتى الاقليمي وربما الدولي
ما يجعل حسم المعركه مساله صعبه هل هذا
صحيح
صحيح هذا صحيح طبعا يعني لكن في رايي ان
ربما يتطور زخم دولي واقليمي بضروره انهاء
هذه الظاهره في السودان وعندما نتحدث عن
انهاء هذه الظاهره ليس بالضروره ان يتم
انهاء بالعنف او باستخدام السلاح الافضل
والطبيعي هو ان يتم انهاء هذه المشكلات
بالتفاوض وبالحوار ان يتم دمج قوات الدفاع
الدعم السريع في الجيش النظامي السوداني
وفق لخطه متوافق عليها بين الجانبين هذا
هو السيناريو الطبيعه او السيناريو الافضل
ان يتم ححسم هذا الاشكال عن طريق التفاوض
وعن طريق الحوار وعن طريق خطه سياسيه وخطه
امنيه متوافق متوافق عليها من القاهره
محمد فايز فرحات مدير مركز الاهرام
للدراسات شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
اعزائي المشاهدين البيان الان للجامعه
العربيه هنالك اجتماع
للجامعه العربيه على مستوى المندوبين
البيان الان يدعو الى ضروره الفق الوقف
الفوري للاشتباكات كافه والحفاظ على امن
السودان
ووحدته اذا بيان الجامعه العربيه يدعو الى
ضروره الوقف الفوري للاشتباكات كافه
والحفاظ على امن السودان ووحدته
ستبقى مع هذه الصور بالصوت الطبيعي التي
تظهر حجم مترابط المعارك اعزائي المشاهدين
اتركهم مع هذه المشاهد بالصوت والصوره
[موسيقى]
اعزائي المشاهدين كنا واياكم مع هذه
المشاهد بالصوت والصوره
لمحيط مقر القياده العامه للجيش
حيث تدور معارك عنيفه كما نشاهد اعمده
الدخان الاسود
واصوات القذائف
وايضا يعني اطلاق الرصاص المتواصل حتى
الساعه يعني المعلومات متضاربه عن حدود
سيطره كل طرف
في هذه المعركه لمزيد من المتابعه اعود
الى مراسلنا فيماوي نزار بقداوي
نزار جديد المشهد الميداني من عندك واين
تتركز الاشتباكات الان
لارتفاع اعمده الدخان من داخل محيط مطار
مروي الدولي والقاعده الجويه العسكريه
اعمده الدخان قبل نصف ساعه لم تكن موجوده
ما تمت اشتباكات الان بدات يبدو ان اليات
ضربت يبدو ان وتيره
الضربه المتبادل عبر الاعين الناريه او
عبر القاذفه او عبر اصبحت الان واضحه
الاننا نشاهد الارتفاع المتواصل لاعمده
الدخان والذهب من داخل قاعده مروي الجويه
هذا هو المعطى الاحدث هو المعطى الابرز
للاشتباكات والعمليه العسكريه التي كانت
مستمره منذ الامس وتوقفت مساء هل يحاول
الجيش وفق متابعتك استعاده القاعده
نزار ونوعيه الاسلحه المستخدمه
الجيش
يتحرك
سريع وهل هذه
اعمده الدخان هي نتيجه لمحاوله قوات الدعم
السريعه للانسحاب ام هي لمحاوله قوات
الدخول
ايه يبدو انفقنا الاتصال مع مراسلين نزار
لنا اعود اليه في سياق هذه التغطيه انتقل
الى الخرطوم مجددا ومراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم ايضا جديد المشهد الميداني
من عندك اين تتركز الشبكات
وموضوع يعني المعلومات المتضاربه في مخص
محيط مقر القياده العامه للجيش
سالم هل تسمعني
سالم
مراسلنا سالم الهاشمي سالم هل تسمعني
جديد المشهد من عندك سالم خصوصا في محيط
مقر القياده العامه
للجيش اي يعني معلومات متواتره بتعرف انتم
اقرب الى الاحداث منا لانه نحن عم نشاهد
على الشاشه هذا الدخان الكثيف صوت القذائف
من العيار الثقيل وبالطبع هذه الرشقات من
العيارات الناريه
نعم هو تجدد الاشتباكات بصوره ايضا هذه
الوثيره تتسارع منذ فجر اليوم تزيد وتنقص
بينه اخرى لكن
في محيط القياده العامه الجيش السوداني
واستخدام باسلحه ثقيله جدا
وتصل مداها الى مسافات بعيده كذلك لان هذه
الاسلحه وصلت الى هناك بعيده جدا القياده
العامه للجيش السوداني التي فيها الاشتباك
العميل بين الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
نعم طيب
سالم هل هنا يعني اخر
مره غار فيها طيران الجيش على مواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع في العاصمه الخرطوم اذا كان
لديك معلومات
نعم بالنسبه
هذه المره متباعده ليست كالمرات السابقه
كانت تاتي هذه الغارات يوم امس وحتى فجر
اليوم كانت تاتي اتباعا
هذا اليوم شهيدنا مروحيات تاتي بين الفين
والاخرى وكذلك الطائرات الحربيه لكن لم
تاتي اتباعا كما كان امس تاتي في فترات
متباعده الان نستمع الى صوت مروحيه تحلق
في سماء الخرطوم الان
سالم يعني لان قوات دعم السريعه اعلنت
انها اسقطت طائره ولكن هذا الكلام يعني لا
ادري هل جرى التاكد منه او نفي من قبل
القياده العامه للجيش
هذا الحديث وانه لا توجد طائره
سيخويها على الاطلاق من قبل قوات الدعم
السريع قال الجيش يتحدث على انه هو يسيطر
الان على كل الاحداث او ان هذه الامور
ستنتهي ويضمن المواطنين على ان هذا الامر
سينتهي قريبا جدا ولم ياخذ وقتا اكثر من
ذلك طيب سالم الهاشمي شكرا جزيلا لك
بالطبع لنا عوده اليك في سياق هذه التغطيه
المتواصله اعزائي المشاهدين هذه التغطيه
متواصله من قناه العربيه للمواجهات في
السودان بعد قليل
يسحقكم الزميل لايف الاحمري في ساعه
اخباريه في ساعه تغطيه اخباريه من قناه
العربيه على ان نلتقي في تمام الساعه
الخامسه
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات